gestern war man noch ganz im zeichen von
military fitness hohe körperliche
belastung viel schweiß heute
regenerative einheit beweglichkeit
training
die nici ich der beta wir sind wieder da
für euch und wir haben heute wieder
einen spezialgast eine
leistungssportlerin die frau gefreite
alexandria synchronschwimmerin aber am
besten ist du stellst du kurz selbst vor
bitte war so und jetzt los ja ich heiße
alexander über sie und ich bin zum clown
schwimmerin und ja sind ganz schwimmen
ist eine ziemlich komplizierte sportart
man muss gut schwimmen können tanzen man
sagt auch oft dass es ist tanzen im
wasser
und ja man braucht viel beweglichkeit
und kraft auch gleichzeitig das was wir
pro palette im wasser kennt man sagen
auch gerne also eine sehr komplexe
grazile sportart aber ihr werdet es die
nächste halbe stunde sehen macht sich
eine eigene meinung die beweglichkeit
ist beeindruckend so viel kann ich
vorausschicken okay um entsprechend auch
einen muskel beweglich zu machen um ihn
zu denen um auch zu entspannen muss man
zuerst eislauf wir haben ein bisschen
temperatur hineinbringen
das heißt ihr kennt das bereits wir
beginnen mit lockerem laufen am stand
das ist uns vielleicht in der
zwischenzeit kurz wie schaut's
trainingsalltag einer
synchronschwimmerin aus haben wir fahren
ziemlich früh an mit training um 36
machen wir auch firmen bis zum 37 wo wir
im wasserspringen und wir machen eine
stunde schwimmen also nur spezifisch
schwimmen für ausdauer und dann technik
höchste technische übungen für unsere
sportart und wir kennt dann weiter mit
der choreografie also mit musikschülern
werde
und ja also an der 630 bereits
aufzuwärmen und dann ins wasser zu
springen ich glaube das ist einmal
erlernt des ausschließungsgrund für ganz
viele von uns also an meine hochachtung
dass ihr das so durchziehen ok dann
mobilisieren dann nicht nur die guido
kasmann mittwoch gehört haben einmal
täglich sondern auch die
synchronschwimmer das heißt einmal kurz
auslagern die beine und wir beginnen mit
der halswirbelsäule zu mobilisieren ja
sie ist einfach so den kopf drehen
rechts und links also die varianten
einheimischer schauen wir mal ob jahren
vielleicht anderer kommt und auch
seitlich also orte schulte rechts links
also ist sport übergreifend mobilisieren
denn alle und entsprechend die übungen
an der relativ die scheiben immer und
nach vorn zu rückgabe ist bei euch
einmal im standardprogramm drinnen genau
dass man alle bewegungsrichtungen der
halswirbelsäule da entsprechend abdecken
können und greifen eigentlich auch okay
halbkreis nach halb von der linken seite
über die brust rollen zur rechten seite
und hin und her wechseln und jemand wir
ja die nicke und auf alle fälle seiner
story zwar geübt im im mobilisieren die
war sie immer auch das täglich und wie
gesagt wenn es ihr zu hause schafft das
auto eklig einzubauen nimmt sich die 56
minuten zeit was braucht es über 10 in
kurzer zeit kam aber extreme folge und
verbesserungen einfach bemerken ok danke
nächstes gelenk was ist so haben
standardprogramm noch von den
synchronschwimmerinnen mit dabei als
schulter und arm schultern arme kreisen
da braucht man ganz viel beweglichkeit
und auch entsprechend vorbereitete
gelenke das heißt arme vorwärts kreisen
große kreise gesetzes und arme rückwärts
kreisen
auch jetzt eine vor eine zurück und
richtung wechseln
das ist jetzt so das standardprogramm
des kennen alle sportler
was haben die synchronschwimmer noch für
übungen mit dabei für arme kreisen abend
seiner armee das ist schlechte hand
einen achter zeichnen in der luft große
bewegung aber wieder wechsel auf die
linke seite
da war es sehr gut was kann man um auch
ein beweglichkeit schultergelenk gleich
haben kombiniert vorne genau mit all den
strom spannung hin und her schwingen
du kennst du natürlich die beine bereits
die knie gestreckt lassen dann spürt
bereits anzug in der gesäßmuskulatur und
in der oberschenkelrückseite drinnen
fürs aufwärmen fürs mobilisieren ist
also nicht ganz so tragisch wenn jetzt
auch aktiv stets das heißt ein leichten
winkel im kniegelenk drinnen habt dann
kannst du die spannung hatte von
herausnehmen
ok dann hätte vorschlag bewegen wir uns
wieder kurz das heißt mit laufen am
stand zwischendrin an felsen
zwischendrin einmal einen kniehoch dazu
einbauen dass man den kreislauf in
schwung bringen und war so du erzählst
du uns inzwischen was war deine größte
sportliche leistung bis jetzt am achter
platz bei der weltmeisterschaft zwei mal
und sechste platz bei der europa sorge
also in der allgemeinen klasse 8a in
einer sport dort ein bisschen
grundschule man bei der
weltmeisterschaft zu werden alle achtung
gut ab also gut gemacht und wo sie sich
in zukunft wo geht die reise hin
sportlich haben wir haben die olympia
qualifikation im märz dem tag hier und
die europameisterschaft immer also ziel
olympia sowie von jedem erfolgreichen
leistungssportler das ziel olympia ist
genau auch für die sehr gut
ok wieder ausloggen nächste übung wie
machen sie das mit der wirbelsäule wie
schaut es da bei euch aus ein bisschen
jetzt es solche übungen einfach so den
körper drehen
ok körper drehen und dann in der
endposition die hände ausstrecken und
das sieht man schon da kommt es gerade
ziele der synchronschwimmerinnen mit
heraus wir haben bis dato den oberkörper
verdreht und die hände einfacher
schwungmasse mitgenommen
und da es bereits eine entsprechende
körperspannung mit dabei hände werden
dazu gestreckt in einer in der
endposition also da merkt man schon mal
einen gewissen unterschied ja wohl
umsonst was er anfasst so seitlich okay
also immer wieder in die
ausgangsposition hände seitlich strecken
und dann über dem kopf körper vertreten
einmal links einmal rechts genau wie
geht's dir mit den übungen mit dieser
doch in dem aufwärmen bereits mit der
spannung da war dann bewegen uns wieder
kurzem stand jetzt machen wir das was
die nici schon gut kann und was die
kampfsportler gut können schauen wir mal
ob die synchronschwimmer da diese
affinität in den kartsport hinein haben
weil es nämlich die hände dazu und noch
mal boxen auf das heißt die hände dazu
ausstrecken
optimal war kennt man kennt kein
unterschied so perfekt ok und wieder
auflockern nicht gibst du unser übung zu
mobilisieren vor wir haben die
wirbelsäule ist das einigermaßen
abgeschlossen bei einer ausnahme
stehenbleiben durchschnaufen hüfte
hüftkreisen ich gehe mal davon aus dass
machen die synchronschwimmer auch als
aufwärmen mit dem aufwärmen genau da
habe kleinere frage wie schaut es aus
mit luft anhalten wie lange müsste im
schnitt unter wasser sein so ohne
bewegung können wir ungefähr drei
minuten unter wasser bleiben und mit
bewegung also während der choreografie
eine minute seite wechseln also
richtungswechsel in bremen okay also ich
wiederhole es noch mit drei minuten ohne
bewegung unter wasser ist überhaupt kein
thema und eine minute mit schwerer
körperlicher arbeit
wer möchte lässt die bordwand probiert
es dann aus aber wenn der andrang zu
stark wird bitte wieder auftauchen okay
das kann man so wie vieles trainieren
und üben da geht relativ schnell was
weiter okay was haben wir noch für die
hüfte
einfach so kreis machen okay das müssen
wir uns genau anschauen wie das geht das
heißt der oberkörper verdreht sich und
der hand ist immer die hand ist in einem
halbkreis mit dabei sonne genau zu und
versuchte das entsprechend nachzumachen
und wenn es qualitativ nicht ganz
perfekt funktioniert reicht es
oberkörper verdrehen ok hüftgelenk und
unterer bereich wirbelsäule haben wir
jetzt mit drinnen gehabt
okay das ganze in einer anderen richtung
an oder war das jetzt nur noch okay
zweite richtung hätte fast übersehen
jetzt da ich sehe da wird kreativ auch
anstrengend und ich denke es geht euch
zu hause gleich wenn ihr das nachmachen
versucht da ist auch der kopf mit dabei
und wenn man die bewegung schon 10.000
mal gemacht hat sowie die wahl sei dann
funktioniert das natürlich aus einem
guss okay wir schauen mal aus wie geht's
weiter machen wir immer so hinken
hervorrufen zurück drücken da kann man
schon eine dynamik auch im bedienung der
hinteren muskulatur wiederum
gesäßmuskulatur oberschenkelrückseite
teilweise vielleicht auch die
wadenmuskulatur thema der bereits unter
spannung haben wichtig dabei lasst den
rücken gerade das heißt die
beweglichkeit nicht aus der wirbelsäule
herausholen sondern aus dem hüftgelenk
dafür dass einmal kurz bieten dass du
das von der seite zeigt das heißt ihr
bewegt der knick kommt in der hüfte ja
und nicht aus der wirbelsäule drücken
bleibt die kerzengerade vor allem in der
vorbeuge dankeschön kniegelenk glaube
ist es ja was machen wir das gelenk
[Musik]
die übung kenner koordinativ nicht ganz
so anspruchsvoll war bewegungen nach
rechts ab bewegungen nach links gaben
die richtung wechseln und ich weiß die
schwimmer haben ganz großen augen ganz
großes augenmerk auf auch auf der
beweglichkeit von sprunggelenk haben sie
da ganz spezielle übungen oder aber wir
werden immer auf wir machen solche kreis
ok in allem recht ist bei reisen in alle
richtungen also rechts und links
richtung wechseln dann nehme ich mal an
die seite wechseln dass beide gelenke
gleichmann sind
und auch die richtung wechseln und sonst
seine zeitung macht mir das okay dass
sie einiges wagen heben das heißt in den
zehn stand nach oben und wieder runter
genau gleich mitmachen nehmen wir uns
bucht sehen sie konnten konzentrieren
ganz hoch ganz runter volle spannung aus
der muskulatur jetzt kurz aufbauen um
die beweglichkeit im sprunggelenk da
einfach zu gewährleisten und
gleichzeitig wir haben natürlich die
wadenmuskulatur damit ganz gut auf ok
wieder ausloggen weil ich so viel
wahrheit keine trainingseinheit kein
richtiges wirkt auch daraus machen
sondern sie ja einen regenerativen
charakter haben das ist wir brauchen die
muskulatur jetzt nicht überlasten und
entsprechend überfordern
okay wir mobilisieren glaube ich sage
mal ganz gut durch oder hast du ja übung
die für dich ganz wichtig ist als
synchronschwimmerin bei mobilisieren
ich glaube ganz gut durch ok wenn wir
die vorschlag fangen wir mit der ersten
bewegung an die erste position ist der
ausfallschritt ihr kennt die position
bereits und jetzt schauen wir uns einmal
ganz genau an wie das bei den synchron
wie man funktioniert und so ausschaut
okay die gebiete auch einmal
ausfallschritt auch da die position der
rücken ist gerade der unterschenkel ist
in einem rechten winkel zum boden wer
jetzt nicht ganz in die strecke unter so
hinein kommt wie es bei dir der fall ist
kann man natürlich ein bisschen weiter
hinten seien wichtig ist dass eine gute
spannung im hüftbeuger drinnen habt und
entsprechend darin die statische dehnung
hinein geht es das ganze manchmal gleich
gemeinsam nur 26 sekunden versuchen die
spannung zu lösen
da kennt sie gleich wieder die atmung
kontrollieren
tief einatmen und ausatmen konzentrieren
genau zwei sekunden nur langsam die
spannung wieder herausholen und gleichen
die zweite position gehen und dies mit
gestreckten beinen nach vor und den
oberkörper nach unten ziehen
damit schaut seine ganz genau auf den
rücken von der wahl so der ist
kerzengerade und das sollte die optimale
position in diesem fall seien genau
nehmen wir uns wieder 20 sekunden
nach zehn sekunden versucht wirklich die
spannung zu lösen und langsam wieder aus
der position heraus kommen und jetzt
kommen das was der auch bei den
synchronschwimmen typisch ist zuerst die
positionsdaten zu belasten die
beweglichkeit zu trainieren und dann in
die dynamik zu gehen das ist jetzt
wechseln zwischen position eins und
position zweit immer gemacht haben nach
vor und zurück hin und her genau also
einmal in den hüftbeuger in die spannung
hinein und einmal oberschenkelrückseite
machen wir zehn sekunden war
wiederholungen
kurz die spannung herausnehmen aufstehen
aus lockern position wechseln zweite
seite nach vor ruhig die muskulatur
bisschen ausloggen ausschüttung wieder
in die opposition hinein gehen und wir
beginnen wieder
wir schieben die hüfte das becken nach
vor und schauen dass man im hüftbeuger
eine spannung bekommen konzentrieren
durchatmen
rücken gerade halten atmen nicht
vergessen
sehen sie kunden noch und langsam die
spannung wieder herausnehmen und die
position nummer zwei einnehmen da
hingestreckt gerade rücken und kopf
zieht richtung knie beziehungsweise
richtung boden habt ihr das
bayern-training auch eine ruhe beim
trainer ist spaß und action dabei also
es ist eigentlich immer denen jeden tag
halbe stunde langsam aus der position
kommen und hier machen auch dazu yoga
okay aber dort aber halbe stunde pro tag
zumindest in seiner beweglichkeit
arbeiten okay wenn die dynamik nach
vorne zurück position eins position zwei
im wechsel becken schiebt vorbecken geht
zurück genau einmal in die bahnstrecke
und einmal in der beuge
nach zwei wiederholungen vor zurück und
kurz aus lockern wieder muskulatur
ausschütteln nächste muskelgruppe dem
wir uns anschauen ist der oberschenkel
die oberschenkelrückseite okay da haben
wir schon die ein oder andere übung wenn
sein herz gemacht das heißt wir mit
bayern erhöht und oberkörper nach vorne
ziehen haben wir bereits gehabt hätte
schauen wir uns eine zusätzliche
variante an dafür die bitte lasst uns
mal vor zeigst was deine variante für
die oberschenkelrückseite ist also
rückenlage haben wir glück gehabt
man kann es zu genau zum anfangen lassen
wir gerne so bevor man jemanden
überfordern das heißt rückenlage knie
zur brust sehen genau da kommen wir mal
rein so fangen wir mal an
und wie geht es dann weiter seitlich
ziehen
ok ich würde aber vorschlagen nur als
geübte synchronschwimmerin möglich ehrt
auch ratsam sich so zu verbiegen und für
den otto normalverbraucher blaimer bitte
bei der variante eins oder zwei die euch
die nicht gezeigt das heißt mit
gestreckten bein und alles nicht so
tragisch ob das jetzt im 45 grad winkel
nach oben zeigt oder 90 grad in der
opposition kommen die
oberschenkelrückseite gut hinein in der
beweglichkeit und wie gesagt das ist die
spezial variante das in grohn schwimmer
und das ist die standard variante die
für jeden möglich ist machen nur zehn
sekunden
und jetzt wichtig langsam aus der
spannung raus kommen langsam die
position verändern nicht ruckartig die
position verändern und die seite
wechseln
kennen sie den oberkörper ablegen knie
zur brust sind so fangen wir wieder an
entspannung lösen sie in sekunden
bleiben die muskuläre spannungen lösen
die position halten und jetzt die
position verändern variante nummer zwei
gestrecktes bein beziehungsweise fast
ausgekugelt die hüfte die immer gedacht
dass kampfsportler habe ja gute
beweglichkeit meiner unteren extremität
aber darauf frisst mich fasst langsam
aus der position wieder herauskommen
muskulatur aus lockern beine
ausschütteln
ich würde vorschlagen nachdem wir jetzt
gesetzt sein stehen wir wieder aufgeben
die position gerät stand und mit dem
kopf richtung knie ziehen die übung
kennt man damit fahren wir wieder mehr
an
da kommen auch rein
oberschenkelrückseite gesäßmuskulatur
geht schon los in der mitte beginnen
wichtig weiteratmen knie sind gestreckt
und die zehn beziehungsweise ganze
fußsohle ist am boden okay ist nicht nur
die fersen am boden sondern die ganze
fußball bleibt am boden position
verändern linke seite rechte seite sucht
sich eine aus genau
auch da kann man schön hinein sind
bleiben weder 30 sekunden in der
statischen dehnung drinnen
die fahrt man ihn konzentrieren
muskuläre spannung lösen
und man merkt wirklich wie die spannung
nachlässt nach zehn sekunden und lang
sind die position wieder verändern
spannung raus nehmen und auf der zweiten
seite spannung aufbauen
gehen sie mit den händen den fuß fassen
wer die beweglichkeit es nicht ganz so
am boden die arme uploader die hände ab
legt es ermöglicht wichtig ist wie
gesagt die knie sind durchgestreckt und
nur so weit sollte ich hinunter gehen
dass diese position auch beibehalten
werden kann noch zehn sekunden langsamer
aus der opposition heraus kommen und
jetzt wie man vorher gesagt haben zuerst
haben wir die statik und dann geht man
in die dynamik hinein das heißt aus dem
gerät stand heraus die rotation griff
links griff rechts so das material
entsprechend dynamisch arbeiten kennen
und wechseln in dem fall bei uns muss es
gar nicht synchron funktionieren weil
die vase hat jetzt auf die nici
umgeschaut wo anfangen mal gemeinsam an
so dass das ganze sind ground
funktioniert also sie kommt aus ihrer
haut heraus die synchronschwimmerin bei
uns ist das nicht so tragisch es muss
nicht perfekt synchron funktionieren
genau und wieder aufrichten ausschütten
aus lockern
wir haben als männer ritten strecke den
haben wir bis jetzt so eigentlich noch
gar nicht so gut trainiert
also trainierte aber nicht gedehnt und
der war gestern ein der belastung
relativ hoch mit dabei ob sie etwa
spezielle übungen wie ihren
rückenstrecke denen kreative muskulatur
entlang quasi schon rücken nach unten
ja wir machen
so wie ich bin ist so ok den kopf also
wer möchte kann das gerne ausprobieren
man überschlägt sie quasi forster kopf
bleibt aber und zieht dann die beine
richtung kopf und die variante nummer
zwei zimmer anbieten ihr bleibt einfach
sitzen und zieht sie jetzt mit dem
oberkörper richtung knie nach vor nur
nicht so wie im fall immer vorher gesagt
haben dass der rücken teil gerade ist
sondern jetzt können es ruhig an
leichten rundrücken haben wir es wohl
man ja in die bedienung vom
rückenstrecke hineingehen das heißt in
die muskuläre dehnung das heißt orkane
jetzt ruhiger mal einen einen runderen
rücken auch haben um darin die dehnung
entsprechend hineinzukommen man nur zehn
hunden
und langsam wieder aus der opposition
heraus kommen indem wir glauben auch der
dynamische bewegung vor und zurück nicht
wirklich einen sinn oder wir machen
sag mir bitte vor wie macht sie das
dynamische und dynamisch vor weil er
dann mehr kräftigungsübungen als wie als
wie entspannungsübungen oder aber das
haben wir schon sehr stark in der
kräftigung der bauchmuskulatur drehen
das braucht man jetzt heute nicht
unbedingt ok also rückenstrecke hammer
was geben als nächstes an
für die beine was machen wir dafür sagen
wir vor es können wir die ruhe machen
also einfach sorgen die position bleiben
ok also eine tiefe hocke gehen ist es da
wichtig dass die standbein ganz am boden
ist oder ist das ja eigentlich schon
okay das heißt nicht probieren mal genau
mit der ferse am boden runtergehen setzt
sich einmal rein so tief ist rein geht
wer es nicht ganz so tief unten ist mit
dem gesäß sak problem wichtig ist dass
in die opposition hinein geht und dann
mal da eine dehnung spürt genau paar
sekunden nur die position halten langsam
aus der position raus und wechseln auf
der anderen seite hinüber ja wieder
einrichten fersen einrichten
die schottische spielerisch spielerisch
aus spürst du überhaupt irgendwas jetzt
gerade nicht jetzt gerade mal so und
dann wechseln mal dynamisch hin und her
20 sekunden dynamisch in die den
position hinein und wieder heraus
aber nicht viel aus mir nach dem stich
du spürst du schon oder ok und die gehe
davon aus ihr zuhause spürt das genauso
gut die dehnung und das ist ja das muss
man wollen den muskeln entspannen und in
die dehnung da hinein zu arbeiten
ok bevor es zu muskulären arbeit wird
hier die forscher auf stehen bei einer
aus lockern
bei anstrengen muskulär wollen was heute
nicht okay und da übung glaube ich für
die beine hormann ob drinnen und für die
gesäßmuskulatur das heißt den hürden
sitz am boden bitte sagt mir das einmal
vor da gibt es auch unterschiedlichste
varianten aber er setzt sich hin und
winkels das rechte bein nach hinten ab
und je näher ihr die verse richtung
gesetzt sitzt desto einfacher kennt
jetzt am anfang einmal sitzen ja aber
welche weiter dass sie die strecke und
gehe desto schwieriger wird es von
beweglichkeit das überhaupt die position
halten kann
und jetzt geht es weiter aus dem
herrensitz genau jetzt haben im rücken
wieder gerade oder man braucht mehr
hinschauen rücken ist gerade und sieht
nach vor so weit wie es geht mit geraden
rücken vorziehen
und da kommen die spannung hinein
oberschenkelrückseite gesäßmuskulatur
perfekt
langsam wieder aus der position heraus
kommen und da glaube ich wird sage ganz
gut funktionieren wenn man dynamische
arbeitet oder naja also kurz hinein
ziehen und wieder kurz loslassen nicht
in einen gelenks oder in einem
beweglichkeit anschlag dort hinein
arbeiten und schmerzen spüren sondern
einfach in die lockere den position
dynamisch hinein und wieder heraus
genau zwei sekunden machen wir das okay
aus der position wieder heraus und
gleich in die zweite seite hineingehen
das heißt das linke bein abwinkeln für
also richtung gesäß 10 10 schauen nach
oben und position einnehmen spannung
aufbauen rücken gerade sehr cool und man
hat immer bessere und der schlechteren
seite
das heißt und meistens fängt mit der
besseren anderes als wenn die zweite
seite jetzt ein bissel act und bequem
ist das überhaupt kein problem
wie gesagt einfach daran arbeiten und
dann löst sich die spannung dann geht
der zug heraus
platzieren sie konnten
und langsam wieder die position heraus
haben wir kurz aufrichten und jetzt in
eine moderate spannung wieder dynamisch
hinein arbeiten
doch zählen sie konnten und wieder
langsam dass der spannung heraus haben
wir aufstehen und durch lockern
was gibts ja übung die tu am
allerliebsten markt mit denen ja für die
hüfte wir machen das ganz okay das
ähnlich jetzt ein bissel dem stoff den
man mit herrn korporal am mittwoch
gemacht haben wo man dann vor und zurück
gehüpft sein schaut extrem schwierig aus
kaarst total leichtere variante für uns
als man das üben können
diesmal das beine nach vorne abwinken
okay
und auch da wieder hinein sind ich würde
vorschlagen nachdem das deine lieblings
übung ist du magst sie so wie du dich
wohl fühlst und macht die zweite
variante oder glaube das passt ganz gut
und dann machen wir noch eine letzte
übung du spürst dass am meisten
okay auch wieder oberschenkelrückseite
das ist anscheinend der neuralgische
punkt den muss man immer wieder aus
lockern und ausdehnen wenn man viel
trainiert braucht man viel zeit zur
regeneration
ok dann gehen wir noch mal langsam aus
der opposition heraus weg sondern auch
mal die seite
tja wird langsam die position wieder
verlassen aufstehen aus lockern
wir haben im november da ewig zuschauen
könnte weil es super grazil ist und uns
super weiterhilft in der beweglichkeit
eine halbe stunde ist nicht länger danke
dass ihr wieder mit dabei war
wir sahen ein nächste woche mit dabei
wenn es dann heißt auf in den
integrierten trainingswoche feet aus dem
lokal
wir würden uns sehr freuen wenn ihr
dabei seid wir sind da haben wir immer
wieder eine unterstützung eines
leistungssportlers der mit rat und tat
sowie heute die frage freute mit dabei
ist danke dass ihr mit arbeits und wir
sehen uns nächsten montag schönes
wochenende